what what got you to africa in the first
place
i've been hearing about this tribe of
people called the hadza
over and over and over and
they were this fascinating group of
people for me they were just this tribe
that were some of the last remaining
hunter-gatherers left on the planet
there's not many left probably numbering
in the thousands
of true
close to being hunter-gatherers left on
the planet these are people who don't
farm they just hunt every day and they
gather food they don't even have
dwellings that are permanent they have
thatched huts they make and then they
break them down they have camps they
move around this area in africa called
lake yasi
another group in africa is called the
ikong which is in namibia botswana and
south africa but i couldn't go to those
places because of covet restrictions but
tanzania was open
so i just decided now is the time i want
to go visit the haza i've never been to
africa but i went to tanzania you fly
into
you know
you fly into right by kilimanjaro you go
to this town that's right by likiasi so
it's like
20 hours 26 hours of flight to africa
then you have to drive four or five
hours from your flight in kilimanjaro
then you have to drive another hour and
a half every morning through the bush to
like find them in the jungle or in the
bushes
yeah so you're you're way out there and
then you just it's incredible like as
soon as we got to meet them they were
super welcoming
and they just let you be a part of the
tribe and we got to hunt with them we
got to hang out with them we sat by the
campfire at six in the morning and 7 30
at night we got to sing with them and
just eat with them i mean i ate
crazy stuff with them so it's just
incredible to see
like baboon brains
would you do it
i mean i'd probably try about anything
it would be it would be a mind over
matter thing it actually was really good
i've had brains i've had brains before
so i didn't think it was going to be bad
afterwards people were all worried about
prions but there's never been a case of
prion disease that actually jumped from
what's creon so prions are
never heard of mad cow disease yeah
this is like a semi-infectious particle
of protein so people have this long
debate our virus is alive people also
debate are prions alive prions are just
a piece of protein it's an amino acid
sequence that makes up a protein and
when it gets into your body it causes
other proteins to misfold so it causes
this chain reaction this oftentimes
aggregate reaction in the brain which
can cause protein misfolding and
neuronal damage there's a disease in
humans called crutchfield yaakov disease
which is associated with certain
genetics and certain proteins and that
is a prion disease and a variant of
crutchfield jacob is mad cow disease so
in britain a number of years ago there
was an outbreak of this mad cow disease
where
by eating the neural tissue the brain
the spinal cord or even the meat of some
of these cows people could get infected
with this prion so it caused this huge
stir this probably is the type of thing
that happens in livestock because of
crowding right factory farming and the
wrong type of treatment of animals and i
think that in this situation they were
actually feeding pieces of cows to other
cows so the reason it was spreading was
because the cows were eating other cow
parts like waste or compost from other
cows
which is probably not a good idea cows
probably shouldn't eat other cows
especially if they're in isolation and
in
these cordoned off you know areas where
they're in sort of factory farms so
that's prion disease
and
people believe that hiv is a virus that
probably jumped from primates to humans
so whenever you talk about eating baboon
brains people think like hiv and prions
but i'm okay
yeah so
okay so then we're gonna back up a leap
to go why why was it that you felt like
this driving force to go to africa and
experience
something more primal and something more
natural and something
that i'm imagining was different than
what you were experiencing at home was
there an impetus was there um something
that was that were you in a situation
that was totally different were you i
don't even know what your job was before
were you sitting at a desk and you're
like screw this i need to get on my
surfboard and i need to go do other
things like why did you end up wanting
to really go to africa especially at
such an interesting time
um
and in life where everybody is you know
scared of everything you're like i need
to get out of here
have you ever seen the movie back to the
future yeah
did you ever want to go in the delorean
did you ever want to go on a time
machine dude i always want to go on a
time machine i am always wanting to go
at all times i want to just like
i want to experience this sort of time
as an illusion thing and jump timelines
and dimensions and
yes all the time so this is the closest
thing i've ever done to being in a time
machine
and that's i think what's interesting
about anthropology and studying groups
of people
who live differently than we do in 2022
you and i know what it's like to live in
new york city or chicago or california
or texas or costa rica in 2022
but what was it like to live in africa
or any of those places 50 000 years ago
or 75 000 years ago and this is the
closest that i thought i could get to a
time machine these people hunter
gatherers that still live on the earth
live so much differently than we live
it's the closest thing to a time machine
it's not a perfect time machine the
delorean's broken a little bit they've
been influenced by
modern humans but they actively
avoid
modernity in their life they know about
cell phones they see our cell phones we
show them pictures of rhinoceros
on the cell phone and they get all
excited and they want to go hunt it but
they don't want to leave their lifestyle
they live
the most similarly to the way that
humans lived 50 to 75 000 years ago of
anyone on the planet right now and it's
you know
just miles different than we do today so
they're so much closer to the way that
humans lived 75 thousand years ago than
anything else on the planet that that
was what i wanted to see where did we
come from that's the question that i was
looking to answer where do we come from
and there are many people who believe
that that hadza are the direct
descendants of homo sapiens that homo
sapien there's different you know we
don't exactly understand where homo
sapiens arose and there's a lot of
different lineages of
homo
the homo genus and there's you know all
sorts of neanderthals and denisovans and
you know different peoples but homo
sapiens
we believe this this that our species
arose
in this region of africa this sort of um
this the old of eye gorge has footprints
of pre-hominids that we believe were the
predecessors of homo sapiens so many
people believe the hadza are direct
descendants of homo sapiens and this is
perhaps the closest thing we will ever
come to understanding where we've been
as humans so what you see there is
fascinating it's just a time machine and
that's the way they they wear animal
skins and they wear shorts that are
dirty that missionaries have given them
but they wear animal skins
for shirts and they hunt with arrows
that they fashion by hand they use bows
that they carve by hand from the trees
in their area and they we saw them shoot
birds and they you know obviously killed
a baboon with us and then they
make a fire with no lighters you know
they us they use wood and they
essentially they rub two sticks together
they have a
uh they have a bow drill type of uh
method and they they also spin the they
spin the wood in their hands and they
get a they get an ember
and they use that on tinder they make
fire in two minutes or less they smoke
the animal they burn the hair off we cut
into it and we're eating the organs and
then so it's just fascinating because
one of the questions that
is so fascinating to me as a physician
is is there
a program written into this homo sapien
dna
that gives us an idea of the way we're
supposed to eat
you know is there a program other
animals pretty clearly have species
appropriate and species inappropriate
diets
do you have dogs i do yeah so i have
dogs too and
like i've been around other dogs and you
know dog farts are a bad thing but my
dogs don't really fart i don't like
smell their farts unless somebody feeds
them something like a cookie or a hot
dog bun i was doing a reel for fourth of
july where i was throwing hot dogs in
the buns saying i wasn't a fan of like
hot dogs and the buns and ketchup and of
course all my dogs just spill [ __ ] yeah
they're [ __ ] they're [ __ ] the
dog just one of my dogs whose name is
ribeye runs into the jungle and just
goes he just goes crazy he eats those
hot dogs he'll he'll eat junk food if i
give it to him right so he'll eat
ketchup and hot dogs and he's eating the
buns and then he has horrible gas and he
farts all over the place and his skin
doesn't look as good so this is just a
roundabout way of saying that i think
that we see this in animals and i think
it's really fascinating but we don't
really think about this in humans like
the question is is there a
species-appropriate diet for humans and
that may be as large or as small as we
want to define it like maybe a
species-appropriate diet for humans is
much bigger than what i'm imagining but
that's what i'm really trying to
understand because when i went to
medical school and residency and before
medical school i was a physician
assistant so i had lots of years of
medical training and i started in
medical school one and a half times
i've been around a lot of the medical
world for a long time like never was i
taught to ask this question
like how the heck is a human supposed to
eat it's almost like we assume we know
how we're supposed to eat but to me
that's the most fascinating question
that no one really has figured out an
answer to and then that the corollary
questions are are different people
different you know we're all homo
sapiens but is is you know is danica
going to eat differently than paul or
you know is are some people going to do
better with more plants or some people
are going to do better with less plants
and then the deeper questions for me as
a physician that are super fascinating
are around how many of the chronic
illnesses that we
accept as inevitable in humans whether
it's heart disease dementias alzheimer's
parkinson's neuro degeneration arthritis
arthritis whether it's rheumatoid or
osteoarthritis thyroid hormone problems
whatever autoimmune disease or chronic
illness you want diabetes obesity how
many of these diseases that we accept is
inevitable are preventable or reversible
if we can align
the diet with what our dna program as a
program is expecting like if there is
actually a user manual written into our
dna as humans
into what we are supposed to be eating
well what have you figured out
could you heal humans right yeah i mean
i agree i think this is fascinating i
ask this question all the time too and i
i test on myself all kinds of things you
know i mean probably the worst test i
did was trying to eat less animal meat
i mean i just truly felt bad for the
animals it was an ethics thing it was a
compassion it wasn't about not liking
the taste of it i mean freaking love
steak um love lamb love duck love elf
you name it like i'll eat all of them um
but i
started eating you know i would have
more fish i would have a little bit of
fish at night but pretty much all
plant-based the rest of the day and then
you're substituting and when you look at
the label of some of the [ __ ] fake
meat i mean it's terrible i'm like wait
what's worse i don't know god and then i
round about thought about well what's
the
what's the value of protein you know
just do we have to have protein do we
have that much protein can we get the
protein from in other ways from plants
or other things and so i went through
that but there's no doubt in my mind
there's no doubt that i feel the best on
high fat animal meat no no doubt and so
i i abandoned i'm totally okay with it i
mean do i want to see the truck driving
down the road that's full of cows
heading to a slaughterhouse absolutely
not
and i don't i feel so bad i
was watching a nascar race and there's
the winner gets a lobster and this thing
is gigantic and i'm just watching it
going oh
and my mom my mom was like what is it
the lobster i'm like yeah
but i just i know that it's you know
makes me feel better so
what um like what has what tests have
you done on yourself i think you were
vegan at some point in time right i was
vegan about 15 years ago for seven
months i had 20 to 25 pounds less muscle
mass on my body so i'm like a moderately
muscled male and you can imagine me with
20 pounds less muscle it was really
skinny i couldn't get a date you know i
would like ask a girl out and she would
say
you're too skinny and that was almost
when the light bulb went off
evolutionarily my body is like you're an
idiot start eating meat like you're
never gonna procreate or even get to
practice if you don't eat some meat dude
like this girl is saying you're too
skinny so i was like okay but yeah i had
a horrible vegan phase it was really bad
gas my gi symptoms were out of control
you couldn't be in the same room with me
when i was vegan
and then you know and i had my own
autoimmune issues i've had my own
autoimmune issues throughout my life
mine are not as severe as many peoples
are but i have eczema and asthma which
is a sort of a family of conditions
known as atp
these atopic conditions so i have atopic
dermatitis which is these red itchy
bumps that'll come up on my wrists and
my elbows and my knees and when i was in
medical school at times i had eczema so
bad i was doing jiu jitsu it would get
infected it would cause impetigo so
that's it's not a bad
thing in general but it can be a bad
thing for a lot of humans and people are
very self-conscious about their eczema
people can get on their face and on
their body it doesn't look good on your
skin to have eczema and asthma is a lung
condition which is fairly serious and
these are autoimmune conditions
and growing up
my dad is a doctor he's an internist my
mom is a nurse practitioner
and neither of them
were taught to think
is our son eating something that is
causing this eczema for him as a kid i
had this i had these little itchy bumps
right i'm eating regular pasteurized
dairy i'm eating processed food
even though my family is medical family
we were eating tb dinners i was eating
seed oils i was eating processed sugars
we'd go to mcdonald's and instead of
thinking
my incredibly intelligent and super kind
father instead of thinking maybe we
should feed our son differently they
give me inhalers and creams
this doesn't solve the problem at all
this is kind of the this is what i've
always been trying to figure out for
myself and why
i don't know i think growing up in a
medical family you get fascinated by
these questions of how humans can live
better i'm not as much obsessed about
living long i just want to live well
every single day i want the quality and
i'm not willing to sacrifice
the quality of my life experience any
day for some empty promise of longevity
especially when that empty promise of
longevity is hard to prove there's a lot
of people out there now saying if you do
this you'll live longer it's like okay
maybe in 70 years we'll find out if
that's true or not right
[Music]